العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
ووليد العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان وجهها
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه بتسيير جسر جوي الى تركيا
وسوريا وتقديم مساعدات صحيه وايوائيه
وغذائيه لتخفيف اثار الزلازل كما وجه
الملك سلمان والامير محمد بن سلمان بتنظيم
حمله شعبيه عبر منصه ساهم لمساعده ضحايا
زلزال
تفاصيل اكثر عن هذا الجسر الجوي من الرياض
ينضم الى مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
عبد المحسن اهلا بك معنا ماذا لدينا من
تفاصيل حول هذا الجسر الجوي الذي يقدمه
مركز الملك سلمان
نعم ميسون بالفعل خلال اقل من 24 ساعه
سينطلق هذا الجسر الجوي محملا بالكثير من
المساعدات الايوائيه بشكل رئيسي بالاضافه
الى مساعدات صحيه وفريق طبي كامل سيكون
برفقه هذه هذا الجسر واول طلائع عادل جسر
ستنطلق بعد ساعات من الان ربما اقل من 24
ساعه الساعه الواحده من ظهر يوم الغد
ستنطلق ايضا حمله شعبيه كبيره ستقوم فيها
مركز الملك سلمان موجهه لكافه المواطنين
والمقيمين في السعوديه للقيام بعمل عمليه
تبرع كبيره حمله تبرع حمله تبرع كبيره
لمتضرري الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا على حد
سواء وكل هذه المساعدات هذه الحمله حمله
ساهم يعني كيف كيف هل هي ستكون اموال ومن
ثم هذه الاموال يتم شراء مساعدات انسانيه
للمنكوبين ام ستكون عباره عن مساعد
انسانيه طبيه غذائيه يقدمها من يريد ان
يساهم في هذه الحمله
بالفعل ميسون هي هذه المساعدات والحمله
التي ستنطلق في منصه ساهم عند الساعه
الواحده من ظهر يوم الغد ستشمل كافه انواع
المساعدات نتحدثنا عن المساعدات
الاغاثيه المباشره او الغذائيه او الطبيه
او حتى التي تتعلق بالشتاء وايجاد الملابس
اللازمه في هذا البرد القارص فبالتالي كل
هذه الاموال التي سيتم ضخها في هذه المنصه
من قبل المواطنين والمقيمين في السعوديه
سيتم تحويلها الى هذه المنتجات بشكل كامل
بهذه الصيغه سيتم ايصالها الى داخل التركي
وكذلك السوري في اقرب فرصه ممكنه سيتم
وصول هذه المساعدات بدءا من الغد وستستمر
هذه العمليه لايام ايضا سيكون هنالك طلائع
الجسر الجوي الذي سيبدا يوم الغد سيكون
برفقته فريق من المختصين سيكون في الداخل
التركي وكذلك في سوريا تحديدا شمال غربي
سوريا بالتنسيق مع تركيا سيتم الدخول
المركز الملك سلمان الى المناطق المتضرره
من
كارثه ومن كارثه الزلزال في تركيا في
سوريا بالاضافه الى تركيا وتقييم الوضع
بشكل دوري وبالاضافه الى هذا الجسر
المستمر سيكون هنالك تحديثات مستمره في
الحاجه الطارئه والعاجله
والمستحدثه بشكل يومي
الاستجابه السريعه لكافه الاحتياجات
بالاضافه الى انه المركز من خلال تصريحات
مسؤوليه قال بانه سيساهم في عمليه اعاده
الاعمار اعاده بناء هذه
المئات من المنازل التي تهدمت والالاف
سواء كان في الداخل التركي والسوري عبر
خبرائه ومختصيه الذين سيتواجدون في كافه
المناطق المتضرره في سوريا وتركيا لتقييم
الوضع بشكل عاجل بالاضافه الى المساعدات
العاجله التي من المفترض ان تصل خلال اقل
من 24 ساعه سيكون هنالك ايضا مساعدات ما
بعد عمليات الانقاذ وعمليات المساعدات
العاجله في عمليه اعاده الاعمار واعاده
بناء هذه
البيوت المهدمه بالتنسيق طبعا مع الجانب
التركي وفي الداخل السوري في شمال غربي
سوريا بالتنسيق مع الجهات والمنظمات
الاغاثيه في تلك المناطق ميسون اشكرك كانت
المحسن الحربي على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل كنت معي من الرياض